one of the Marine Reserve attacked Luis
Torres Luis I I first heard about this I
thought to myself this is what I'm glad
my mother and father have gone to their
final resting place because III don't
even know how they would react to this
they would say what has happened to our
country that something like this could
happen to two Marines just trying to you
know go and see the sights in the City
of Brotherly Love
take us through what happened that day
well thanks for having me Laurel so me
and corporal gudinas were downtown
Philly in the Penn's Landing area around
there
we've never been in that area ourselves
that was our first time we were with our
entire squadron to meet at the Liberty
Bell by noon so not only we were there
we were mandated to be there by our
command to be there for professional
military education that's what we call
PME just to check out the landmarks
check out the historical exhibits and
regular civilian attire and lo and
behold we will never know later won't we
will fall victims to these activists we
were there at noon and my first party
was simply to grab a bite to eat and so
me and Godinez together we go find
somewhere a casual restaurant we get
something to eat we have plenty of time
to kill that evening was our our Hilton
we had our rancor bought at the Hilton
Hotel so to celebrate the 243rd birthday
of the Marine Corps so that was our plan
being at Philly okay when did you buy
these these characters take us right to
that moment what happened because are
you at your are you dressed in your your
full Marine uniform at that moment no
not at all well okay like I said we
arrived there at 12:00 and casual
civilian attire okay up to three o'clock
we I'm sorry interesting but so you you
get closer and a couple of these
characters come up to you and ask we saw
traces report are you
you're proud like you got marine and
probably you didn't know it probably
meant it's a far-right group that has
these these kind of little rallies how
did it feel to be called a white
supremacist as someone of Hispanic
descent that is a extreme irony to us we
find we found it very ironic and
confusing as well I don't know who would
look at us and suppose white supremists
neo-nazi or anything like that godinez
is Mexican I am Puerto Rican nonetheless
we're two Hispanic Marines on duty that
day during duty hours and to be
confronted by white folks not supposing
that there is anything racially charged
to her towards us until he asks us are
we proud boys and then later on the
crowd just calls us these racial slurs
and then later on cause us racial slurs
for being a Hispanic heritage the irony
was just colossal Semper Fi my friend
Merry Christmas I'm sorry you had to go
through this thank you I'm glad you're
okay and and give our best to Alejandro
and I know he had he had a rough go of
it and he's still still suffering the
results of these these injuries this is
an Tifa my gosh this is the United
States of America disagree disagree
violently if you want but not this this
is criminal this is thuggery and it's a
type of domestic terrorism thank you so
much we really appreciate your time